there's many reasons why i i dislike
zayn and there's many reasons why i'll
always always be on his side
liam payne is giving one direction fans
all the teams including why he dislikes
zayn malik after the boy band took an
indefinite hiatus
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
liam stopped by the impulsive with logan
paul podcast where he shares how he
really feels about zane while liam says
he dislikes the pillow talk singer he
also explains why he'll always be in his
corner because liam says he empathizes
with how zane was raised if i had had to
go through what he went through
through his gr his growth and whatever
else my parents are overly supportive to
the point where it's annoying at times
and they don't even mind saying that and
zayn zane had a different upbringing in
that sense and um you can always look at
the man for where he is and and say oh
yeah whatever that guy's a right but at
the end of the day once you understand
what he's been through to get to that
point and also whether or not he
actually even wanted to be there liam
also touches on zayn's legal troubles in
2021 zane was placed on probation for
four counts of harassment after having
an alleged altercation with his ex gigi
hadid's mom yolanda at the time zane
adamantly denied striking yolanda listen
i don't agree with any of these actions
i can't commend some of the things that
you've done i can't be on your side for
that what i can say is i understand and
i hope that your only hope is that at
some point in their life the person on
the other end of the phone wants to
receive the help that you're willing to
give them
liam also references when zane got into
an altercation with logan's younger
brother jake in 2020 specifically
calling out this tweet from gigi at the
time defending her man and dissing jake
gigi
tweeted
at jay calling like ugly and irrelevant
and that went crazy viral she tweeted
something about get yourself like a
respectful man or something yeah yeah
that one didn't age very well
then conversation shifts to one
direction as a whole specifically how
liam almost came to blows with the
bandmate there was one moment where
there was an argument backstage and
someone one member in particular threw
me over wall
so i said to him if you don't remove
those hands it's a high likelihood
you'll never use them again liam stays
tight-lipped on whether harry styles
niall horan louis tomlinson or zane
started the confrontation but the 28
year old says that was enough for his
bandmate to take their hands off him
nobody can drag me down
[Music]
liam who was the last to go solo with
his ep in 2018 says it was difficult to
write his own music
but it's his comments about his debut
singles performance that has some fans
raising their eyebrows
yeah we did the first song billion
streams
i think it outsold everybody within the
band and i was the last to go and i
never expected that i don't even know
what i like so what can i write songs
about and while the guys have all
released solo projects liam says he has
a newfound appreciation for the band's
success and reveals his one regret until
the dusk clears it's like you don't
appreciate it for what it is and and
regrettably so actually because i wish
i'd understood it more while i was in
the middle of it but like i mean you
know there was a point where you know
people were saying oh you could probably
fart barbara black sheep on a mic and it
would go to number one and i was like
you know you just didn't appreciate it
as much as you should have really we
never got time to celebrate that was the
one thing in one direction that i always
hated
[Music]
you